especially in times of crisis we're all
dependent on ensuring that basic
supplies are available to the population
and medicines protective equipment and
other necessary goods have to reach
hospitals doctors practices and nursing
homes the outbreak of coronavirus has a
major impact on European transport the
measures introduced to slow down the
spread of the virus have also slowed
down and sometimes paralyzed transport
this delays the delivery of goods and
can cause shortages the priority is now
to ensure that the main axis of our
traffic in the European Union are
unblocked today we issue guidelines on
the green lanes to member state I set
out for objectives to make real progress
on Europe's roads first crossing the
border on a green lane should take
maximum 15 minutes this weekend we had
some crossing points with more than 40
kilometers of queues this is a waiting
time of up to 18 hours this has to stop
second the green lanes should be open to
vehicles carrying any type of goods our
supply chains in Europe are closely
integrated we need to ensure the free
circulation of all goods third national
governments should suspend restrictions
for instance bans to drive at weekends
or at night this is an exceptional
situation we need to be flexible and
fourth we need to reduce the paperwork
for transport workers of all
nationalities to enable them to cross
borders more rapidly health checks at
the border can be useful complementary
measures against the virus but they must
be organized in such a way that the free
movement of goods does not come to a
standstill the fight against the virus
will take a long time the strength and
the means to win that fight will come
from our great single market and that is
why we must
that is why I and my team are working
for it every single day